the Joe Rogan experience 76 percent of
people in England and Wales have a UK
passport okay I've got a UK passport do
you yeah I'm dual citizen so look at you
work well I'm a little upset with Prince
Harry but other than that it's really
well humanity he left the throne or
whatever the [ __ ] he did now I mean you
know it doesn't it make sense kind of
well it probably makes sense because you
know I don't know that he's the sharpest
tool in the box and he's probably
thinking I can we can make a lot more
money if but they're not supposed to
make any money off of being a member of
the royal family and yet they've
trademarked apparently sort of their
their brand
Duke and Duchess of Sussex and they're
not allowed to make any money off of the
royal family so they were given
allotment allowances living expenses
much it's a significant amount look
they've got a house on the grounds of
Windsor Castle they're gonna continue to
live in so I guess here's my point they
can't do whatever the [ __ ] they want but
it would have been nice if they told
their grandmother so that she didn't
find out about it on the news I thought
that was kind of it the Queen spotted
dick move but yeah remarkably accurate
she's so she found out on TV but you
know they want to be financially
independent
you know they trademark to Duke and
Duchess of Sussex in a variety of
different ways apparently and and she's
gonna go back to doing whatever she did
to turn him into a Kardashian that's
exactly what's gonna happen
yeah well listen they're already so
popular all they need to do is start an
endorsing [ __ ] makeup lines and
sneakers and watches and [ __ ] next scene
Oh Jed's a millionaire yeah but she's
got a massive following on Instagram
which I suspect she wants to know well
how much do you think they'd make find
out how much they make how much do they
make from the royal family my pop not
public I think they're high vision well
he got no bear them yeah I don't think
they're hiding it but I think they make
a million a year yeah oh yeah more than
that I mean a key god I think from from
his mother from I think as an
inheritance he got some nine million
dollars area then she's probably worth
about six million on a row for acting
career I didn't know what she was acting
in but he's off to Vancouver and the guy
doesn't even know there's a rabies issue
there there's a [ __ ] 13% bat rabies
problem there buddy right right is gonna
go he's gonna go to Vancouver looking to
move part-time to Canada there's a
reality show I guarantee you some creepy
producer got a hold of them and go guys
listen you're wasting your time over
here in England it rains too much yeah
look she's you're pissing away the money
she's worth yeah he's probably thinking
yeah I want to get us and but then he
came out and said well we're not gonna
move to the States supposedly he came
out and said this is all so I can't
believe we sound like page six or
something but he came out and said you
know we're not moving to the States
until the Queen gets but they're her
grandchildren's money isn't oh my god
she wrote the Queen received fifty eight
million dollars free of tax from the
sovereign grant in the 2016-2017 fiscal
year damn what kind of goofy [ __ ] is
that they give them fifty eight million
dollar a million dollars one hundred and
three million dollars in the next year
it's good to be queen to help finance
the extensive renovations of Palace we
need analysis pretty impressive but
imagine being a poor person and you find
out that the Queen who literally does
nothing is making a hundred million
dollars in the year yeah I see this is
where I I I don't think I could ever say
anything negative about the Queen I've
it's I think I got a tremendous amount
of it I feel like her like she's you
know grandma but I - I've got because
you have a dual citizens yeah yeah
everybody's like brainwashed over there
yeah but she's I mean but she has been a
remarkably consistent but she's got a
shitshow of a family
my country think about all the public
service she does oh god I see credible
this just this alone worth a lot of
money think about each wave is now
apparently 103 million dollars that's
that's a significant amount no I anyway
I don't know how it got down this one
but it's hairy they left yeah oh that's
right they left to go to Lincoln rabies
town so he is making a hundred million
dollars a year he's probably making ten
all right it's a significant amount so I
it's you know I get it okay they want to
go again who cares but making the money
off the royal family and I can't make
money off the royal family at the royal
brand so it's like you know the idea is
you're getting paid enough yes what a
woodsy system they just give them money
for free yeah to be a rod in the British
taxpayers are saying like what the [ __ ]
we're gonna keep subsidizing them
they're gonna go to Canada and we're
gonna keep paying them and they're gonna
live part time here they're not gonna do
that any any of the representative
representational work or what if it's
real I don't know you got to show up at
events
[Applause]